we've spoken a lot about monopolies
monopolies monopolies and we've spoken a
lot about perfect competition
perfect competition and we kind of view
them as polar opposites over here very
you have exactly one player here you
have many players in a monopoly you get
to set the price and the quantity here
you have to be a price taker in a
monopoly there's huge barriers to entry
in perfect competition there's no
barriers to entry what i want to think
about in this video is are there other
situations or especially are there terms
for other situations that are in between
and to think about that i'm going to
draw a spectrum i'm going to do a
two-dimensional spectrum i could
probably think of more variables where
there's nuance between these terms but
these are the two big ones so in one
dimension i'm going to think about the
number of competitors there are so this
is the number
of competitors
competitors
number of competitors and obviously a
monopoly is one competitor perfect
competition you've got a bunch
you've got a bunch of competitors
so i'll put one right over here and a
bunch of competitors if this was zero
then there wouldn't even be a market to
speak of no one is doing is
participating there in this axis in the
vertical axis
in the vertical axis i want to think
about how differentiated how
differentiated the competitors in the
market are how different are their
products or their brands
differentiation differentiation
in the market and this was low
differentiation and this is high
this is high differentiation so let's
think of a bunch of industries and think
about where they sit here and then i'll
introduce you to two new words other
than just a monopoly or perfect
competition
so let's just say that we live in a
world where there's there's 50 producers
of screws and all of those crews are
completely identical and and so if one
producer charges even a penny more no
one's going to want to go to them
because they can get the exact same
thing from one of the other of the many
producers so that would be a case right
over here low differentiation all the
screws are the same and there's a bunch
of competitors so that's about as
perfect as perfect competition can get
in the real world so bunch
a bunch
of un of identical
identical
screw manufacturers i'm not sure if the
actual screw market has a bunch of
competitors but let's just assume if it
did then you would be sitting right over
here pretty pretty close in the world of
perfect competition in the other
spectrum you imagine your utilities in
most places in especially the us but
probably the world there's only one
utility there's only one pers one entity
that's managing the power lines a lot of
times because of that it's actually run
by the government but in most of the us
it's a rebel it's a regulated private
company and so here you have one player
one player and you can debate whether
it's low differentiation or so high
differentiation that it's the only
player but let's let's just stick it
right over there low differentiation
this right over here might be a utility
utility and that's about as close to a
monopoly or that actually is a monopoly
they are the only player there mono mono
comes from one poly comes from seller
one seller that would be a utility
now there are things that are in between
so for example if you thought about your
let's say the the telephone providers in
your area there normally are a few
people who can provide phone service
especially with the age of internet
telephony now the cable companies are
starting to provide phone service and
the telephone companies are starting to
provide internet and cable service so we
could think of that market so let's put
this market right over here so the
number of competitors is low so it's
going to be here and they are somewhat
differentiated they might give you a
different cable box or might offer you
slightly different levels of bandwidth
or whatever else so they're somewhat
differentiated right over here so i'll
call that the
cable
cable internet
internet
telephone providers
telephone
telephone providers right over there
then you can think of markets you can
think of markets where there's a bunch
of competitors there's a bunch of
competitors but they are somewhat
differentiated and i can think of fine
dining so let's say so here there's a
bunch of restaurants in any place that
sells you know nice food that they
really define themselves by the quality
of the food that they produce so they're
highly differentiated each restaurant is
unique they're the the chefs have
specialties and all the rest but there
it's but there's a bunch of them
so right over here i will put fine
fine
fine dining you could also imagine you
know name brand clothing they're they're
very differentiated certain designers
certain materials all of those type of
things but there's a bunch of them
so name brand
name brand clothing
name brand clothing
it's not quite perfect competition it's
very competitive there's a bunch of
players there but they don't they're not
selling the same product they are very
very differentiated to some degree you
almost feel like even though there's all
this competition they have a monopoly on
their own product another one could be
you could imagine something like you
know high-end laptops or high-end
computers or
or you know nice computers
or maybe i'll just say computers in
general
computers in general computers in
general some people
might want to go for an apple that's
what they've associated with and some
people might want to go for a sony so
maybe i'll put branded computers up here
so branded
branded computers
computers
up here but then you could also have
something like the unbranded pc market
and that might be something closer to
here where you might have these random
manufacturers you don't even care some
manufacturer from overseas you don't
even care but they're saying they're
using the they're using the same
processor the same memory chip they're
saying using all the same things so
they're much less differentiated so this
might be right over here unbranded
unbranded and that tends to happen with
the personal computer industry that
you're like well they're using the same
intel chip they're using the same memory
they're all running windows whatever
else there's not a lot difference
between them so those actually start
getting closer to this perfect
competition
so the whole reason that i've introduced
you these ideas to you is that there are
names there are names for these things
that aren't quite perfect competition
because they're highly differentiated
and there are names for these things
that aren't quite monopolies because
they have a few providers these right
over here so you know we could put other
things around here so i'll circle this
general area we would call these
oligopolies alegopolis
oligopolies and ale this comes from
this part right over here and i'm not an
expert in greek but this comes from few
and obviously the poly once again just
with monopolies comes from sellers
comes from sellers so this means few
sellers and oligopolies and we're going
to study this in much more detail
they're not quite monopolies they can't
set the price and the quantity and they
can kind of depending on the oligopoly
depending on the market they might start
acting more like a monopoly the players
could coordinate with each other so that
to their mutual benefit or they might
become fiercely competitive even if
there's only a few providers so
oligopolies can kind of can kind of in
their personality characteristics they
can either look more like monopolies or
they can look like kind of very
competitive industries and these things
up here where these are quite
competitive industries these are quite
competitive industries but they are
highly differentiated to some degree you
could say that for example in branded
computers apple has a monopoly on
selling apple computers it doesn't have
a monopoly on computers obviously
there's many many people who can provide
computers
but they have a brand if someone wants a
an apple computer you have to go to
apple it's almost you know it's a
self-evident statement but they but it's
highly differentiated highly branded and
so
they have a monopoly on their product
but there are many many many other
competitors who are out there that won't
let them just set price because they can
offer products that are that serve the
same purpose but they're differentiated
in some way and so these these players
up over here we would call these or
these markets these are
monopolistic
monopolistic
competition
competition and when you first hear that
it sounds it sounds more because the
word the first word you hear is
monopolistic but this is more this is at
least in my mind closer to perfect
competition than it is to a monopoly
because this is a or at least the way i
viewed in my mind monopoly is completely
completely uncompetitive while this is
still highly competitive it's still not
quite as highly competitive as perfect
competition but it's close you have a
monopoly in just your product but there
are other not two different similar pro
there
are other products on the market that
whose prices affect your price or
that there are other alternatives i
should say in the market that that that
will affect people's demand for your
product and the best giveaway between a
monopolistic competitor and a perfect
competition is that there is some
differentiation with the products over
here there is some maybe branding here
there's maybe some quality difference
between the products